لا لا لا لا   لا لا لا لا   لا لا لا لا
ذات صباح حلو رائع جنب البركة خمس ضفادع
قرووو قرووو قرووو قروووو
غنوا وبشكل متتابع قفز الأول خلف ذبابة
طاردها جريا في الغابة كم ضفدع جنب البركة
قرووو قرووو قرووو قروووو
في الأجواء الخلابة بقى هناك أربعة
أربعة أربعة بقي هناك أربعة
غطس الثاني في البركة ليشاكس فيها سمكة
قرووو قرووو قرووو قروووو
كم ضفدع جنب البركة جلسوا من دون حركة
بقى ثلاثة بالنسمات غنوا أحلى الأغنيات
قرووو قرووو قرووو قروووو
بالبهجة يقضوا الأوقات بقي هناك ثلاثة
ثلاثة ثلاثة بقي هناك ثلاثة
صعد الثالث للشجرة جاع ليبحث عن ثمرة
قرووو قرووو قرووو قروووو
كم ضفدع جنب البركة بقي هذه المرة
بقي هناك ضفدعان غنوا بهدوء و أمان
قرووو قرووو قرووو قروووو
بنقيق مثل الألحان  بقي ضفدعان اثنان
اثنان اثنان بقي ضفدعان اثنان
انزلق الرابع في الماء فرحا في تلك الأجواء
قرووو قرووو قرووو قروووو
كم ضفدع جنب البركة باق وبكل استرخاء
هو ضفدع باق واحد جلس هناك ويشاهد
قرووو قرووو قرووو قروووو
متبق ضفدع واحد يسبح في الماء البارد
واحد واحد بقي ضفدع واحد
غاص الضفدع في البركة وتعالى جزلا ضحك
قرووو قرووو قرووو قروووو
ما عاد هناك ضفادع في المعزوفة مشتركة
كم ضفدع جنب البركة استرخوا وبلا حركة
قرووو قرووو قرووو قروووو
لم تبق أي ضفادع لا ضفدع جنب البركة
صفر صفر لم تبق أي ضفادع